I hate to break it to the trumpeters in
our audience but no the FBI director
James Comey did not reopen an
investigation into Hillary Clinton's
emails tons of headlines saying the
investigation is back on tons of
right-wingers and Hillary haters saying
David you need to talk about this the
investigation is back on Hillary Clinton
is maybe within hours of an indictment I
must have received nearly I don't know
hundreds of YouTube comments over the
weekend demanding that I talked about
this hundreds of tweets and emails
saying you have to talk about this David
because otherwise you would be very
biased let's start with what did happen
and what did not happen I think one will
help us figure out the other first of
all an investigation was done in two
disgraced former congressman anthony
Weiner's computer emails turned up
during that investigation may relate to
Hillary Clinton how is this possible
well uh the the then wife and now
they're in the process of divorcing
anthony Weiner's then wife Huma Abedin
is a close aide to Hillary Clinton this
was a shared computer and therefore
there's no surprise at all that there
would have been emails on that computer
involving Hillary Clinton in some way
shape or form let's now look and I can't
believe more people in the audience
didn't do this this is crazy Pat let's
read the letter that FBI director James
Comey wrote and figure out what it says
and to begin with you will see uh really
the the key paragraph is the middle
paragraph in connection with an
unrelated case the FBI has learned of
the existence of emails that appear to
be pertinent to the investigation into
Hillary Clinton's personal email server
that is I am writing to inform you that
the investigative team briefed me on
this yesterday and I agreed that the FBI
should take appropriate investigative
steps designed to allow investigators to
review these emails to determine whether
they contain classified information
as well as to assess their importance to
our investigation going on to say
although the FBI cannot yet assess
whether or not this material may be
significant and I cannot predict how
long it will take us to complete this
additional work I believe it is
important to update your committees
about our efforts in light of my
previous testimony I would invite my
friends in the media to read the letter
because the letter does not say that the
investigation into Hillary Clinton's
emails which ended with a statement from
FBI director James Comey that charges
were not warranted that is not back on
in other words the FBI pad is not
reexamining the previous findings
they're saying there are emails here
which relate to Hillary Clinton in some
way we need to look at those emails we
need to determine whether they contain
classified information and we did need
to look into whether there is any
connection at all to Hillary Clinton's
private email server or anything related
to that that's all this is saying yeah
the whole media has been
sensationalizing the story and just
basically in daiting her themselves we
don't know if this has anything to do
with the case whatsoever no I mean
people are already voting like it's time
to it's time to get this investigation
going yeah I know that this has nothing
to do with NFL football in the New
England Patriots but remember that
entire deflategate thing Pat involving
uh new england patriots quarterback tom
brady and some under inflated balls and
the report came out and it said well i'm
paraphrasing but it's been determined
that it is more likely than not that Tom
Brady had some general knowledge of the
fact that the team's staff was aware
that he preferred balls inflated to the
low end of the inflation spectrum Brady
under-inflated the balls himself was the
conclusion of many again Comey said
we're trying to figure out whether these
newly discovered emails contain
classified information that might be
relevant to the Clinton server probe
which has not been fully reopened as an
investigation right wingers going cuckoo
for cocoa puffs totally off the rails
worse than what a Sarah Palin's speech
about 18th century Russian literature
would go the problem though is that even
if right wingers merely think the
investigation has been reopened it could
hurt Hillary Clinton it could and I know
you you're right early voting has begun
but it could hurt Hillary Clinton and
that's why the motivation of this is
being discussed and we've heard justice
officials say you know the FBI doesn't
really comment on ongoing investigations
former Bush attorney general Alberto
Gonzales was on CNN this morning and he
said I don't get it this is a Republican
we're talking about I don't get it
because the the policy is not to comment
on ongoing investigations and we're not
going to know anything by november eight
that's the truth and like the
deflategate story this is kind of a
story that keeps coming back right yeah
and James Comey he was kind of damned if
he did damned if he didn't cuz if we
waited after the election then he would
have gotten a lot more scrutiny from
right-wingers and it seems like he was
just kind of trying to cover his bases
this actually goes back to something
that other justice uh uh officials legal
experts have been saying which is the
original press conference that Comey
gave actually was the mistake because
the FBI does investigations all the time
and more often than not they never
comment at the conclusion of those
investigations right think aboot if the
FBI regularly commented on
investigations that don't go anywhere it
would be a constant stream of press
conferences where the FBI Isis here's a
hundred investigations we did and none
of them turned up anything criminal and
we're not going to be moving further now
you could make the case well this was
related to the election it was of
national interest in some way you can
make that case but ideally these
organizations these organizations are
not political and you could argue pad
that even the original press conference
to announce that nothing was going to
happen that arguably was mistake that
opened up the door to this entire thing
right i mean this is the whole reason
why they want to get this over and done
with back in july the fact that it's
resurfaced now with a week before the
election I mean it's really just a case
of bad timing